I was an eight-year-old kid in the mid
1990s I grew up in southern Philippines
at that age you're young enough to be
oblivious about what society expects
from each of us but old enough to be
aware of what's going on around you we
lived in a one-bedroom house all five of
us our house was amongst clusters of
houses made mostly of wood in corrugated
metal sheets these houses were built
very close to each other along unpaved
roads there was little to no expectation
of privacy whenever an argument broke
out next door you heard it all or if
there was a little something-something
going on you would probably hear that
too like any other kid I learned what a
family looked like it was a man a woman
plus a child or children but I also
learned it wasn't always that way there
were other combinations of work just as
well there was this family of three who
lived down the street the lead of the
house was called Lenny Lenny had long
black hair often in a ponytail and
manicured nails she always went out with
a little makeup on and her signature red
lipstick Lenny's other half I don't
remember much about him except that he
had a thing for white sleeveless shirts
and gold chains around his neck their
daughter was a couple years younger than
me now everybody in the village knew
Lenny she owned and ran what was the
most popular beauty salon in our side of
town every time their family would walk
down the roads they would always be
greeted with smiles and occasionally
stop for a little chitchat
now the interesting thing about Lenny is
that she also happened to be a
transgender woman she exemplified one of
the Philippines long-standing stories
about gender diversity when it was proof
oftentimes we think of something as
strange only because we're not familiar
with it or we haven't taken enough time
to try and understand in most cultures
around the world
gender is this man woman the Academy
it's this movable non negotiable
distinct classes of individuals we
assign characteristics and expectations
the moment a person's biological sex is
determined but not all cultures are like
that not all cultures are as rigid many
cultures don't look at genitalia
primarily as basis for gender
construction and some communities in
North America Africa the Indian
subcontinent in the Pacific Islands
including the Philippines have a long
history of cultural permissiveness
an accommodation of gender variances as
you may know the people of the
Philippines were under Spanish rule for
over 300 years
that's from 1565 to 1898
this explains why everyday Filipino
conversations are peppered with Spanish
words and why so many of our last names
including mine sound very Spanish this
also explains the firmly entrenched
influence of Catholicism but
pre-colonial philippine societies they
were mostly Animists they believed all
things had a distinct spiritual essence
plants animals rocks rivers places power
resided in the spirit whoever was able
to harness that spiritual power was
highly revered now scholars have studied
the Spanish colony archives also tell us
that these early societies were largely
egalitarian men did not necessarily have
an advantage of a woman wives were
treated as companions not slaves and
family contracts were not done without
their presence and approval in some ways
women had the upper hand
a woman could divorce her husband
own property under her own name which
she kept even after marriage she had the
prerogative to have a baby or not and
then decide the baby's name but the real
key to the power of the pre-colonial
Filipino woman was in her role as
Babylon a collective term for shamans of
various ethnic groups they were the
community healers specialists in Irbil
in divine lore they delivered babies and
communicated with the spirit world
they performed exorcisms and
occasionally and in defense of their
community they kicked some ass and well
the Babylon was a female role there were
also in fact male practitioners in the
spiritual realm reports from early
Spanish chroniclers contained several
references to male shamans who did not
conform to normative Western masculine
standards they cross dressed and
appeared effeminate or sexually
ambiguous adjusted missionary named
Francisco Cena said that one man he
believed to be a shaman was so
effeminate that in every way he was more
a woman than a man all the things that
women did he performed such as weaving
blankets sewing clothes in making pots
he danced also like they did never like
a man whose dance is different in all he
appeared more a woman than a man well
any other juicy details in the colonial
archives thoughts of never ask
as you may have deduced by now the
manner in which these pre-colonial
societies conducted themselves didn't go
over so well all the free loving
gender-variant permitting gender
equality wolf Ness class viciously with
the European sensibilities at a time so
much so that the Spanish missionaries
spent the next 300 years trying to
enforce their to sex to gender model
many Spanish friars also thought that
the cross-dressing Babylon were either
celibate like themselves or had
deficient or malformed genitals but this
was pure speculation documents compiled
between sixteen seven and nine and
sixteen eighty-five called the Berlinale
manuscript mentions male shamans
marrying women the Boxer codex circa 59
II provide clues on the nature of the
male Bible and sexuality
it says ordinarily they dresses women
act like prudes and are so effeminate
the one who does not know them would
believe they're women almost all are
impotent for the reproductive act and
thus the marry other males and sleep
with him
as men and wife and have carnal
knowledge carnal knowledge of course
meaning sex now there's an ongoing
debate in contemporary society about
what constitutes gender and how it
should be defined my country is no
exception
some countries like Australia New
Zealand Pakistan Nepal and Canada have
begun introducing non binary options and
their legal documents such as their
passports and there are permanent
resident cards in all these discussions
about gender I think it's important to
keep in mind that the prevailing notions
of man and woman as static tenders
anchored strictly on biological sex are
social constructs in my peoples case
this social construct is an imposition
it was hammered into their heads
for hundreds of years until they were
convinced their way of thinking was
erroneous but the good thing about
social constructs is they can be
reconstructed to fit a time and age they
can be reconstructed to respond to
communities that are becoming more
diverse and they can be reconstructed
for a world that's starting to realize
we have so much to gain from learning
and working through our differences when
I think about this subject I think about
the Filipino people and and almost
forgotten but important legacy of gender
equality and inclusivity I think about
lovers who were some of the gentlest so
as I had known but could not be fully
open I think about people have made an
impact in my life who showed me that
integrity kindness and strength of
character of far better measures of
judgment far better than things that are
beyond the person's control such as
their skin color their age or their
gender as I stand here today on the
shoulders of people like Glenn II I feel
incredibly grateful for all who've come
before me the ones courageous enough to
put themselves out there who live a life
that was theirs and then the process
made it a little easier for us to live
our lives now because being yourself is
revolutionary and to anyone reeling from
forces trying to knock you down and cram
you into these neat little boxes people
have decided for you don't break I see
you
my ancestors see you there blood runs
through me as they run through so many
of us you are valid and you deserve
rights and recognition just like
everyone else
thank you
[Applause]